do you remember something that was said
to you in one of these UCLA writing
classes that you never forgot chant
definitely Richard Walter said you know
nobody wants to see you know the film of
the village of the nice happy people
that one because it's so true yeah
and also he said something which is in
in Hollywood all you do is graduate to
the next level of disappointment you
know like I think usually the example
that you write the script but it doesn't
sell you know it's it's short but it's
not distributed it's distributed but not
for not in great venues so you basically
just graduate to the next level which is
very grounding you know it's very
grounding advice that you know it's
you're you're always gonna be walking
the tightrope in this industry you know
no matter how well you think you're
doing you're always walking a tightrope
very interesting so also coming with
more of universe saying like the
European mindset of just try it and see
what happens which I like that I like
that mindset do you think that coupled
with that piece of advice has helped you
to be like you know what I'm gonna try
it and yeah why not I'll submit to
Sundance and some people their first
film I mean that what a major
accomplishment but to always like you
know keep your your feet on the ground
you know because because I mean that's
something that he he we would say to us
you know as as a screenwriter like the
the secret to success is self motivated
you know speculative writing you know if
you just like sit around and you wait
for people to come to you that's not
gonna happen you just need to have your
own engine and you have to keep moving
forward regardless and as that would
then sort of at what point when you
heard that did you then go and approach
mr. Reynosa was it at Compton high and
ask him to then work with you with your
feature did you hear that before or
before don't you delete okay yeah you're
very interesting I think that Richard
Walters class was one of the first ones
that I took at UCLA for screenwriting
great do you think that that other
people not just that statement in
general but would react to something
like that you know we maybe I'm more of
this old mindset where people kind of
expected to be picked for things and I
don't think that's the case anymore or
maybe it's less though do you think do
you think there was a reaction to people
thinking that I have to be the one to
like drum up excitement or or not I mean
some people want to be picked and
there's also a feeling of I've arrived
if I'm picked if I have to push this out
then it must not you know you know what
I'm saying but I think that's an old
mindset do you think that the newer
generations are of the mindset of I need
to keep working at this and I'm the one
that makes this happen yeah I mean I
think definitely like what I hear every
every young creative in LA say all the
time is that the Hustle is real yeah
okay right you can never get comfortable
you know just because you know things
are good now doesn't mean that it's that
they're gonna stay that way so you've
really got to just keep keep working
keep collaborating keep making and just
you know stay stay focused because you
know I've had you know very successful
filmmakers say to me that you know the
reason that I'm still making films and
the colleagues that I you know worked
with or grew up with are no longer
making films it's not because I'm more
talented than them it's just I kept
going when they gave up that's the
difference
it's just persistence and and focus and
drive and determination like that's
that's what is going to keep you moving
forward
you